every second in the world whether you're
running for mayor trying to get money
for your pta change people's opinions on
something persuade your kids to do
something no matter what you are trying
to do in the world the game of content
and distribution is how the world works
[Music]
the garyvee audio experience
hey everybody welcome to an episode of
the garyvee audio experience i'm really
excited because i haven't done a podcast
with another human being next to me in
what feels to be like two years so i'm
incredibly excited uh for our guest
today if you follow my content at a
scary level because it's maybe been a
little while but i would often be asked
during q a call it five six seven years
ago before
timing's tough these days uh about well
gary you just talked about this but what
brands are doing it right and at the
time
i was incredibly fascinated with a brand
that i thought was doing influencer
marketing on instagram as well as
anybody i had seen and i do a lot of
watching all the time then now and
forever
and so i started kind of just mentioning
jim shark without really knowing whom or
what
again if you really really know me
legitimately didn't even google it or
look it up or went to the website just
saw it in the flow and would mention it
several years later
met uh some of the key executives were
in my office he's sitting in the
background right now and then a little
later uh met the gentleman that is with
me now uh who is the founder of the
company ben why don't you uh why don't
you introduce yourself to the leader
nation um
yeah no thanks uh yeah my name is ben
francis uh founder and now chief
executive jim shark um jim sharks
fitness apparel brand we were started i
guess during the social era everything
that we do is all about community
um when did you start the company uh
2012. so 2012 i was 19 years old i was
just starting university at the time um
and so i as a kid i wanted to be a
bodybuilder so
i would i would massively admire a lot
of the big bodybuilders over in
california
and i wanted to essentially be like
those guys but i was never big enough i
just didn't have the muscle mass
so at that point bought a sewing machine
screen printer and started hand making
the clothes myself uh fast forward to
today and
play with me a little bit there you go
from i'm going to be arnold
schwarzenegger to i need a sewing
machine yeah help me how many how many
put it together like you you knew you
wanted to start a t-shirt and a fashion
brand no it wasn't that so it was
fitness so i just loved fitness so as a
kid wasn't amazing at school wasn't
misbehaved or anything just for whatever
reason i just couldn't get on board with
it it didn't it didn't sort of it didn't
resonate with me i understand that um
then i joined the gym at 16 i think it
was
and then that taught me structure that
school hadn't taught me it taught me
that i go to the gym five days a week if
i'm feeling tired happy whatever i still
have to get it in and then that
structure i then applied it to school
life and then i did well at school i
managed to get into university which was
massive okay so as a kid completely fell
in love with fitness and that that was
my then ambition was to be involved in
fitness i wasn't actually at that point
desperate to be involved in apparel or
supplements or equipment or anything
like that just a macro i'm going to be
in the fitness game yeah
and so
talk me through
you know i had a very similar
moment in my life it just happened at a
very very very very young age whereas in
third or fourth grade
i remember david johnson in my class
like made me miss seven tackles and he
scored like nine touchdowns in backyard
football and i decided there that i was
not going to be a new york jet
football player but i decided that i was
going to buy them instead and so i have
when you just went through what you just
said it really clicked for me i i smiled
so you
you love the discipline it makes all the
sense you're totally infatuated
are you at 17 and 18
trying to figure out if you have the
muscle mass to go into that world or you
kind of always knew
and to be honest i just knew because i
think there was other people my age that
were just so much far ahead um so i knew
at that point that i wasn't going to be
able to do that now when i said the gym
got me sort of doing well at school it
was at that point that then i started
studying i.t and i learned how to
develop websites and apps okay so at
that point all the websites and apps
that i was making it would always be
around fitness it would be either a
little fitness forum or it would be a
fitness iphone app and i ended up making
i think it was about six different apps
and websites all centered around fitness
before gymshark okay
then
basically none of those transacted none
of them sold products and to be honest
it was more of a
almost challenge to myself oh how cool
would it be to create something that
would transact
um so i thought supplements because
naturally supplemental is the first
place people get it and at this point at
this point are you pretty astute to
instagram are you posting there are you
watching it are you living yeah so
instagram wasn't as big a thing back
then so this was like 2011 2012. it was
more everything was on facebook facebook
pages was like the thing youtube is
obviously huge yes um so why i basically
i went to there was a mate of mine that
actually worked at a supplement shop and
i said to him right at the time i was
working as a delivery driver at pizza
and i was earning about i think it was
like four or five pounds an hour and i
went to him and i said can i buy some
supplements off you because i'm making
this website i want to sell supplements
online he basically said yeah i'll do
you a deal and basically the minimum
order was eight thousand pounds worth of
supplements
i'd never heard about let alone seen it
right so that was like completely off
the cards so at that point i thought
right what i'll do is i'll drop ship
supplements so load it up the website
with hundreds and hundreds of different
supplements somebody buy something i'll
deliver it yeah exactly that and
basically you would make i mean our
first order it took a few months to get
first order was 50 pounds and i think
one or two pounds was profit but i'd
achieved my albeit very low goal of
transacting in fitness online
did that for a little bit and slowly
realized that the margin just wasn't in
dropshipping it wasn't like a long-term
model
and that's when i was looking at people
like arnold schwarzenegger ronnie
coleman looking at what they were
wearing and i was actually buying
product from the states and i'll never
forget i was buying like these stringer
tanks and they would come in and they
would just drown me it looks like i was
wearing like my dad's
dad's top as a kid right completely
drowned me so i thought right let's try
and make our own and it was at that
point sewing machine screen printer and
started to hand make the product
ourselves
and when you say we so that was that was
me and louis who's i co-founded the
business with
later on help from my brother as well
and then some of our friends and then we
sort of just started to hand make these
products and even though we put it on
the website we were almost just making
it for one another because we were all
in the gym every single day um and over
time basically i so as kids especially
in late teens didn't watch loads of
telling or didn't watch much tv it was
all youtube and all of my heroes were on
youtube
and because at the time youtube was this
new and upcoming thing i basically would
send out the product to some of my
favorite youtubers and again because
youtube just wasn't a massive thing they
would look at the product and they would
talk and i ended up making friends with
these guys over in california in germany
in the uk who would then give us
feedback on the product and like i said
just became friends
um
we then sold more of this product online
and we did better and better and better
and um going back to my sort of love for
fitness i'm really fortunate because in
the in the area that i'm from which is
in birmingham in the uk one of the best
fitness events in the world they always
had it it's an event called body power
and as a kid i would always go every
single year we'd always go be like a
pilgrimage for us and then in the period
where jim sharp was first starting i had
like a massive gut feel to be at this
event i thought i don't know how but jim
sharp need to be at this event because
this is this was like this was the dream
right
um went to the guy that runs the show i
think it was it was about three grand at
the time for uh for an event but we made
revenue at that point so i thought we
had 12 months to pay for the three grand
i'd be able to find it in a year so
basically put down the order we said
we'd take a stand and over the next 12
months just hand-made the product and
save the money for the event
as the event was coming round it was in
may by sort of start of the following
year so a few months before the event we
had enough money to fly over these
youtubers and influencers to the event
build a good stand take product to the
event
and basically the brand just blew up at
this event no one else was doing it
we were a completely open shop in a
world that was very much like selling
products selling products selling
product we were like come in here talk
to us meet the guys the athletes if you
want to buy a product you can
yeah and if you're not don't worry and
by the way after the event we'd all go
down and lift together whether you were
a general fitness person that wanted to
buy the product an athlete one of the
the small number of staff members and
what we inadvertently did was started to
build a community just at the grassroots
level by going and lifting with people
after this event
and then prior to that event we were
selling about two or three hundred
pounds a day worth of product so it was
like four or five hundred dollars a day
then after the event
um sorry through the event all of all of
these lists that we were doing were
posted on facebook which facebook and
youtube which is where everyone was at
the time and the brand started to go
viral because i'd actually turned i i
couldn't i couldn't both have the
website on and at the event because all
that all the product was made so i
turned the website off that weekend
came back after the weekend having gone
viral on facebook and youtube
and in the first half an hour after the
website went live we did 30 000 pounds
worth of revenue from two or three
hundred pounds a day and then that was
when and that was in 20
2012 2013 that's when it really started
to move
so it makes sense that when instagram
because instagram was starting was
happening but like at the beginning so
instagram was coming up then and here i
don't know what it was like where you
were it was very much like the sort of i
don't know what you call them like indie
kids it was almost like super super
filtered like everyone had everywhere
very very hipster
brooklyn san francisco yeah that was the
first year of it for sure and then we we
just thought you know what it seems cool
we just i we started using it i was more
on facebook at the time and we moved on
to instagram and we just started posting
on instagram and was the company always
called jim shark yes so the company was
always called gymshark but we we've
basically changed our logo through the
years
so i said as a kid i wanted to be a
bodybuilder that was the ambition so at
the start it was to build bodybuilding
clothing so the logo was like a
muscular cartoon shark yes i remember
actually actually it wasn't long after
that first event
we realized that um
the bodybuilding market as much as i
loved it we wanted to grow beyond that
right yeah
so the brief sort of to myself was i
want a logo that appeals as much to that
bodybuilding market but as everyone else
and the brief was it has to appeal to my
mom as well as me
um so that's when we we built this sort
of shark head logo that we use today and
then we sort of started to venture out
more into fitness
what um what was kind of so obviously
that huge event first what was the next
big
quote-unquote moment you think in
building this business because let me
jump in here and make this not just
about ben and jim shark and make it for
all the listeners
what what you just heard is the same old
thing i mean this is i'm gonna go to the
grave
people laugh when i say the word
arbitrage now in my real life but i
can't help it it's just what it is
every second in the world
whether you're running for mayor trying
to get money for your pta sell sneakers
uh
change people's opinions on something
change the way people dress a new
haircut style get people to drink
cleaner stop supporting something
support something no matter what you are
trying to accompl
persuade your kids to do something no
matter what you are trying to do in the
world
the game of
content and distribution is how the
world works
the game right right now
this is content and distribution there
are a lot of people listening and but
the variable is what's going to come out
of ben's mouth for everybody's listening
right now their perception of you and
the brand from a filter of this
community will be completely predicated
on what happens here in the next 15 20
30 minutes now whether that's 10 seconds
on tick tock
or the first two seconds of a pre-roll
youtube ad that's even two minutes long
or a piece of direct mail a billboard
walking through
an airport and looking at a sign it's
all just the same game
at every moment eighty percent of the
world is overpriced for the attempt to
convince somebody of something the tele
outdoor billboards are up 15
around the world over the last decade in
a world where in that decade every
passenger no longer looks outside
bad deal right you know a lot of people
know where i feel about this whether
it's nft or tick tock or discord right
now good deal and this just ebbs and
flows and i think what i what it's fun
for me to hear this story because i
don't know this story it makes so much
sense because what you did in my opinion
because i pick up watching it in the
wild somewhere around this point as the
next year is
the rep
of facebook and youtube
made you more prepared to be even better
at it at instagram and even the story
because you brought some people to that
event you were able to see that the
personality arbitrage those athletes
whoever you brought to that booth that
was the was a massive arbitrage both in
people at the event wanting to come and
see them but then also the content they
were putting out into the world that led
to this 30 000 day that that's
i always say there's this thing where
when something special is happening once
you see it you can't unsee it yeah you
didn't need to watch my content read a
business book or go to a seminar to
realize there's a
thing going on here let me go committed
you're a kid at that point and for
everybody who's listening
that's what you're looking for you're
looking for
the underpriced moment in time so many
of you that are listening right now is
funny i just took a flight here to the
uk and i was reading a bunch of dms and
i still
still in the last 24 hours i probably
had seven or eight people just flat out
dm thanking me for pushing them so hard
two years ago on tick tock and that was
the moment for them after seven or eight
years of getting no traction seven or
eight years of getting no traction on
instagram and youtube
and and this will continue to forever
happen
and so again i want to take this this
lesson break from this interview
it's always going to be this
procter gamble is the biggest consumer
package goods brand in the world because
they were the most aggressive on
television commercials in the 1950s
period end of story amazon
is the biggest company in the goddamn
world or at least one of them
in the world
because it was the most aggressive buyer
of google adwords in the early 2000s
there's always an arbitrage
tell me just a little color on your next
arbitrage whether it was scaled
instagram or something else yeah so next
steps it sounds really weird by the way
the the things i'm talking about given
the fact that we are everything we do is
online and it's all on social but we did
that event really well and to your point
we noticed that so then we spent all of
our money go one we agreed to do the
event again next year and then we flew
to cologne germany and did an event over
there so there was a big event called
fibo which was twice the size of the
event here we did that the following
year we did uh arnold ohio we went to
california australia germany uk so the
events thing just got bigger and bigger
and bigger and exactly the same as that
first event we were there we had the
team we had the athletes we had the
community we would lift in the gym after
we would all and build that community
and interestingly enough fast forward
eight or nine years now surprise
surprise where are our key markets and
our key areas where those communities
were built the uk germany australia uh
california places like this so
we built up these communities now as we
go doing all these things instagram is
building people are following following
us on instagram on youtube and facebook
they're following the whole athlete team
so one we're building up this community
but two we're starting to work out
exactly how our business works and i had
a lot of big big learning curves in
terms of how to run a business right how
to build teams and i had to completely
reinvent myself several times so
in the early days rocking up to an event
and basically saying i think we need to
do this event because my gut tells me to
is fine and that really works because
you can move the business in a really
quick way but then all of a sudden
you're building teams and it can't just
be what ben says because that's not
particularly scalable i had to then
learn to one build teams work with
people and then start to articulate
reasons as to why then it gets even
bigger and i have to then learn to
articulate a vision speak like publicly
on camera understand better operations
finance logistics tech solutions how to
build a foundation of the business which
at the time i had no idea right i was
purely brand and product focused because
those are my true passions so i had to
learn to one learn to grow look to
reinvent myself and three learn to love
areas of the business which i probably
didn't naturally lean into as much as as
an entrepreneur do you think that you
need to learn to love those areas or do
you think you need to find people who
love those areas and learn enough to be
dangerous to be able to manage those
yeah probably probably more the latter
more the latter especially now at the
start when you haven't got the resource
you have to sort of wear all the habits
so i think you have to for me i had to
really get so passionate about them now
we're a much larger business you're
right you build you find the best people
in the world that you possibly can
afford and you get them in that seat
it's really weird as i was listening to
you i've been having a very interesting
three weeks at vayner x where
i
feel that i've been too complacent for
the last five years in being too
executive life and
i'm
patient and empathetic and i don't
micromanage but i've been signaling to
my leadership team
look i'm i'm too right about where the
market's going and i'm too passive in
pushing you there because it's
uncomfortable for you because you can't
see it the way i can see it and so i'm
going to start being a little bit more
aggressive in 2022 and 2023
to do what i know is going to be right
and and it was funny because as you were
talking i'm like huh what an interesting
arc for a chief executive who founded a
company in the beginning like i've never
historically been concerned about this
concept of it's not scalable because
it's you because i also know that at
amazon or apple or tesla or procter
gamble it's shocking how few people
actually run the company the great
secret of the world of business is the
biggest businesses in the world are
really run by seven 12 15 people
i'm talking companies 150 000 200 that's
just the punch line of reality of it um
but
it's so interesting i would go be so in
everything then you go through that arc
you you create scale but what happens is
you build a company that potentially can
be not as sharp yeah well i but i had to
change a lot right so and i was an avid
voucher of your content particularly in
the early days and you would talk about
leaning on your strengths focusing on
difference so what i did in the early
days was purely i had this this moment
right where it was focus on my strengths
or work and my weaknesses and
i sort of try and zoom out of what ben
wants and think about what jim sharp
needs and jim sharp needed ben to be
incredibly strength so it was at that
point we brought in a chief exec so
someone else called steve who's run the
company brilliantly up until a few
months ago when i came back into the ceo
role he could then look after to the to
a degree running the business and i
would go brand product marketing and
obviously i would have founder duties
directed
but for on a day-to-day basis that was
all i focused on and i got really really
really good at those things and that was
really powerful for me because having
steve there to look after the other bits
meant i could fail in those areas
without consequence so what the way i
would sort of describe it is i could
jump into the finance department mess
around and learn almost like mess around
and break things knowing that it would
always be looked after by our cfo and
steve and that's the way that i learn by
actually physically doing the same exact
way and like being in there and actually
being able to do it myself i mean there
was periods in in product i'll never
forget this where we needed to build a
particular range so we all just jump on
a plane fly out to the factory for a
week and just make the range and then
come back when it's done so now in the
chief exec role
the context that gives me i understand
the product process i understand the
brand process i've been to every single
event i understand the marketing process
and because i've been able to spend time
in ops go to distribution centers live
and breathe it i understand the
foundation of the business as well and
the reason i can do that at 29 is
because steven the chief exec role
allowed me to essentially fail freely i
grew up in an environment where i did
every single thing in my dad's store so
it was so easy for me at 22 to run it
and i remember when i started getting
into corporate world i was impressed you
know as an entrepreneur you have a lot
of cynicism towards big companies
because they're slow and they do they do
things great they do things poorly but
as you were talking i'm like you know
that's one thing that i do think the
fortune 500 world does do well if you
look at who ascends into a ceo role they
make her or him bounce around in all the
categories so they can taste it it was
fun like when i was like again be
similar to not like googling your
company and seeing who you were i don't
tend to look up stuff i just very
similar i just live it and i was like oh
they moved to christian to product he
used to be in marketing wait christian's
the ceo now oh that makes sense he did
all these she did all these things so
before we get out of here
what you know
what i was really excited about having
you on with is that
you're of the age and have had the
decade that a lot of the audience that's
listening
is embarking on
and definitely aspires too
um i think you've been really strong in
articulating certain parts of that
journey right now
i have to assume given how popular jim
shark is with so much of the youth and
where it was built to your point a brand
that's truly built in you know i'm
running around madison avenue saying
brand is built in social because they
all believe it's built intelligent
uh and
your company is a true testament to that
um
what are your go-to pieces of advice for
the kids that are like i want to be like
you because i'm assuming you get a
shitload of that yeah um to be honest i
think it's probably fairly similar to
what you talk about i think
self-awareness is key so that if i
wasn't self-aware as to my strengths and
weaknesses and couldn't approach them in
a logical way then i think we wouldn't
be where we are today i think it's
important for
entrepreneurs and ceos to separate
themselves from the business because
they are is a separate entity albeit so
intrinsically linked like jim shark is
my baby but i have to think about things
from a gym sharp point of view
and something that i think a point we've
done well but i think we could do better
at is it's very rare
for something to work for a prolonged
period of time so i think we were
talking before right about you with
email email worked but then there's a
point where
very quickly and it almost comes out of
nowhere that it doesn't um and then
sorry that's not to say that email
doesn't work so i think there's a huge
huge value in it it's not the same level
of arbitrage things change quickly in
such a big way and by the way in your
business
product and marketing
at the core
both change a lot yeah right like like i
it was so funny drock are you still
wearing let me see your pants real quick
or you changed them
on on the flight you had you like you
and many people are wearing yeah the
bottoms right and i was literally as we
were boarding the plane to london i you
know i was a little ahead of you on the
ramp yeah and you were walking and did
you see me look
at the sneakers i wasn't looking at the
sneakers which would have made sense i
was looking at the fact that over the
last 18 months that level of band on
pants is what people rock with and what
i was thinking drock was holy [ __ ] 20
years ago my number one goal when i
bought jeans was how wide could the
bottom be because i had to cover as much
of my shoe as possible because that's
what was in style right and now i'm
looking around all the dudes like
everything is like super tight right and
like that's it you know for me
that wake-up call the only time that i
felt like i would almost compare it to a
fighter
the only time i was rocked in the ring
like oh [ __ ] i might get not was
absolutely that 2002 2003 thing where i
was like how did i this tenacious young
ambitious dude fall into this lull where
i became completely one dimensionally
vulnerable to just what i do on email
and and i could feel myself milking it
and squeezing it and it felt really
uncomfortable and that's probably why i
was so quick to move to myspace
friendster curiosity because i'm like
okay that's maybe something i can do and
then boom youtube twitter coming the
rest and then and it shook me
to the point where i think i'm very
aggressive on looking for the next tick
tock
real quick before i lose you because my
brain just went there because the next
thing i'm looking at is discord you said
and i want everybody to hear this you
can rewind it you said the word
community an enormous amount of times
and i and i do think
what is going on right now
um and and everybody in this kind of
general sense of our universe is aware
of what's going on with like the reddit
robin hood stuff on buying stocks i
think i i think the discord thing really
has my attention i really do believe
that
the facebook group discord thing is very
real facebook group for that 45 to 90
year old discord for that 18 to 44 year
old for every brand i'm drinking a joe
in the juice
another good european based brand that's
going global
i think i do i do predict that and which
i hate to do because it hasn't really
happened yet so i'm vulnerable here but
i think most brands are going to have
discords and have them in a real way
because i do think community
is
been subtly hidden in the comments
sections of social
and i think discord with nft land is
very clearly showing people it's always
been that
and and what's interesting is to tie it
all into a knot because it's how i lived
with wine library tv
i did a lot of real life events there
too and have always naturally gravitated
towards them as well
because they're just community anchors
but i think and then on that note as
well you're right there's so much to
lean into online and you see so much
about people saying like offline is dead
the high street is dead and when you
hear that i think your ears will prick
up right and go if that's what's being
said there's an opportunity there and
there are people that do do it
incredibly well so like community comes
in all different shapes and sizes i
think to your point and i love that
where my brain went is exactly what
retail is going to turn into in the next
30 years is community hubs right the
store is going to become so different
than what your mom grew up with what i
grew up with like
you're gonna be required to make that a
place where somebody actually wants to
go that hap no different did you pop up
at these events that happened to maybe
also want to buy something because
a lot of stores and a lot of retail has
been and i split many companies into two
different categories right you've always
got brand and utility yes and
like you wouldn't go to a store now
purely for a utility from a youtube
utility point of view because you can
shop amazon it can be at your door in
two hours so why would you go to a store
so
brand as a as a brand you have to look
after your community and i think offline
will be a place where people to your
products
to being a community hub as we wrap up
here i uh i want to make a fun
announcement to my community i am
more protective of my time than ever
very secretly i just want to cancel
everything and just only focus on v
friends because i should uh and probably
my best quickest path to new york jets
however um
ben and i did eventually meet during
covet and things that nature and i'm
happy to announce uh i wanted to save
him being on the podcast for this moment
uh that i'm joining the board of jim
sharp which i'm incredibly excited about
i don't need you to talk about why i
think i want you to talk to people
on how we bring them value
how how do you think whether it was with
me or just in general how do you think
when you have your baby when it's your
company
you're now stepping into back into kind
of a ceo role even though i know what a
founder ceo really there was a lot of co
ceo going on in that relationship with
steve but how do you think about board
members for the people here who are
looking for maybe not everyone's at the
scale that they need a board member but
i do think a lot of people ask me can i
be their mentor and i'm always sad
because i have no shot of that i don't
have the time but how does somebody
who's listening right now if they're a
youngster even if they're 62 and they
could be a youngster in business because
it might be their first entrepreneurial
venture they've had a 40-year
professional career what's your advice
as you're starting to court people like
myself to the board
how do you think about bringing in a
mentor or a board member how do you
think about that um well yeah i think it
depends on the size of the business
right because i never thought we would
need a board like i didn't really know
what a board did really until what like
six months i remember saying to you i'm
not totally sure how a board will work
but let's let's try and work it out and
remember to be honest though my approach
has been one i again just always try and
surround yourself with the best people
possible when i was a kid and i was at
the gym i would do that i would always
say i would go and pick people's heads
at the gym like you just go and ask
questions all the time whoever it is
and that's where i learned so much can i
can i sneak this in real quick for fun
what is the biggest miss for the normal
person around the gym what is the
if i ask you one or two what's the
biggest easy if you want to gain a
little muscle mass or do it right
what do you what do you see as the
common the people that don't go as
hardcore as you the drocks of the world
right for example who wants to stay in
shape because he probably is a little
vain but but is not like really
consuming an enormous amount of content
to be like but but would want to like
maybe put on some what is the biggest
mistakes one word if you could if you
could fix everything it'd be consistency
because like if i see so many people go
seven days a week for six weeks and then
never again for a year and then they do
it again whereas you'd sooner go twice a
week for a year right than just like
non-stop for school mine is where you
were going
food i
covered because i wasn't traveling as
much mike and i mike fakanti my trainer
and i who's been with me for a long time
i had mike for three years then jordan
for two years now mike for three years
i've had eight years now of like
consistent training i've put on more
muscle during covid than i did the
entire time because i had a very weird
thing
i
was too hot and cold if i worked out in
the morning i would eat very tight
during the day because i put in the work
and i was like [ __ ] that [ __ ] cause it
was so scale not muscle yeah
if i didn't work out and that was very
rare for the first five or six years but
the last two or three years i've had
more missed days because we were just
the amount of travel i did they were
always with me and we just kind of like
toned it a hair down
if i didn't work out i would eat more
loose
during cobin i went to reverse which is
far more of the ideal state which is
when i would be rolling or soft tissue
or fascia or something a little or just
abs i would eat incredibly light
when i was doing muscle work like real
lifting i truly truly put in the protein
against the work and it was
significantly yeah makes a difference
so that's what it is drock that's why
you're struggling
all right let's let's let's wrap this up
what are what are you most excited about
in in the
gym shark land in fitness land in
consumer marketing land and product land
let's take this very macro not
necessarily
very detailed jim sharks about to launch
a lollipop more of the macro of this
whole world what are you seeing um
i think similar to what i said earlier i
think we we have to rethink the way that
we see so many things i think i'm seeing
a lot of signs similar to what you
mentioned around email and a lot of the
social platforms that live today i think
to your point discord and tick-tock and
places like that will be the area to get
eyes on brands but also to truly build
communities
going back to what i said earlier i
think
offline has always worked i think
there's the way that it works has
completely changed and i think that's
what we're going to see in the next few
years what about on the product side
like back to the joke about the pop is
there i think so from an apparel
perspective i think the opportunity for
innovation is massive because i think
you're going to see i think you're going
to see
materials innovation at a rate that
we've not seen before particularly from
a sustainability perspective whereas
before it was all around sweat wicking
stretch whereas now i think it'll be
about being recycled and recyclable and
having the performance properties being
a sustainable one right it's like after
you're done working out if you soaked
your shirt just throw it outside because
it'll just become part of the ground
maybe not that extreme
but
what about on the footwear
last question on the footwear side is
there is there innovation opportunity
for people working out i've been seeing
a lot of weird stuff right before covet
like at the gym like people not wearing
shoes at all different socks like just
been seeing what yeah what is this i'm
wearing i'm wearing i'm wearing
barefoots i think but they laugh at me
for wearing these i i think i think
there's a massive opportunity that's why
i asked a question by the way i'm like
what is he wearing what are those
it seriously was subconscious that's
exactly what just happened
no i think it's not the same i think the
opportunity is massive i think there's
opportunity in sustainability i think
it's all about building out true
performance products but also sort of
innovations in the way that the products
delivered as well
brother
excited to get to know you
much more uh congratulations on
everything thank you that would be a
great day
youtube bachelor what's up it's garyvee
first of all thank you so much i hope
you're doing super well during these
times
i also want to ask you please subscribe
because my commitment and exploration of
youtube is about to explode stories
polls more content more engagement more
surprise and delight this is the time to
subscribe i hope you consider it and i
hope i see you soon